Voiceover: Most viral videos
involve like a baby panda sneezing,
or a Korean pop star's
infectious silly dance,
but in 2004, hedge fund
analyst, Salman Khan -
this is not the Bollywood star, by the
way, Salman Khan, for you Bollywood fans;
this is a different Salman
Khan - discovered that the
video tutorials he had made
to explain algebra to his
12-year-old niece became
unexpectedly popular on YouTube.
A couple of years later, he left the world
of finance to found the Khan Academy,
an educational organization
that today provides
over 3,000 free video lectures
and companion exercises online.
Six years and almost two
hundred million views later,
Khan has a plan to reform the classroom,
which he outlines in his new
book, "The One World School
House, Education Reimagined."
He joins us now.
We'll play a couple of his
video excerpts in a minute.
Salman Khan, welcome to WNYC.
Voiceover: It's great to be here.
Voiceover: At what point did you
transition from running the Khan Academy,
creating and sharing these videos,
to advocating for a major reform
of the educational process?
Voiceover: There was never
a hard line when it started,
through this whole adventure,
first working with my cousins,
then the YouTube videos,
and then eventually getting
funding for this not-for-profit,
and building up the interactive exercises,
we've been interfacing a
lot with the school system,
famously, the Los Altos school district
in northern California started using us.
When they asked for ideas, I said it
seems like there's an opportunity here
to not focus class time
on lecture anymore,
and instead use it for interactivity.
The lecture can happen in the
student's own time and pace.
We can go to the self-paced reality.
It, frankly, worked out
well for all involved,
and we started experimenting
with other schools.
Then, researchers, education
historians started coming up
to me and the rest of our team.
Actually, there's a lot of
research that backs this up.
It's called mastery-based learning.
The way that we traditionally learn,
where these students are grouped
in these age-based cohorts,
this is not how humans
have always learned.
We've inherited this from Prussia, a
nation that does not exist anymore.
I go into depth about that in the book.
Voiceover: Good old Prussia.
Voiceover: It seemed like some
of these old but proven ideas
about mastery-based learning,
about self-paced learning,
could now be implemented in a
practical way, using the technology.
Voiceover: Is this what you call
Swiss-cheese learning in the book?
Voiceover: Yeah, once again, the
Prussia model had a positive motive.
It was the first time that people
said, "How do we educate everyone?"
If you go 300 years ago,
only the elite got educated.
When they thought about
that problem, they said,
"Well, it's the Industrial Revolution.
"How do we make a lot of anything?
"We put 'em on a line.
"It moves at a pace.
"At each station, something happens.
"Some of the product is good.
"Some of the product isn't so good."
So, they applied the same
principles to educating children -
big batches of kids,
throw knowledge at them.
Some of them will get it.
Some of them won't.
What's happening with the Swiss cheese is
as they go at that set
pace, it just accumulates.
That's why you see, I think,
otherwise very capable kids,
they get to algebra, they get to calculus,
and they just hit a wall.
Instead, we say, "No,
work at your own pace.
"Master concepts.
"Once you master concepts, then the
next concept's going to seem intuitive."
Voiceover: As we mis
European metaphors here -
the Prussian model, the
Swiss-cheese learning -
here's a small taste of
what Salman Khan does.
This is a clip from a video
posted just last week,
and I should mention it has
almost 10,000 views already,
and it explains probability
with a Monte Carlo simulation.
This is about a minute long and
it begins with a special guest.
Basketball fans, listen up.
Voiceover: It's LeBron here.
I've got a quick brain-teaser for you.
If I'm down three, with 30 seconds left,
is it better to take the three,
or is it easier to take the two
and attempt to foul a bad free-throw
shooter, and get another possession?
"Here's my friend Sal with an answer."
Voiceover: That's a very, very
interesting question, LeBron.
Calculating the probabilities
of if you were to take a three,
what's your probability of tying the game
and then being able to win in overtime?
That can be done on paper, but
the scenario where you take a two,
and you attempt to foul the opposing team,
and they might make none,
or one or two free throws,
and then you might get another
possession and you take another two,
that's more complicated.
You could attempt to do it on paper,
but instead I've written a
little computer simulation here.
This type of a simulation is
called a Monte Carlo simulation.
Literally, it'll run the scenarios.
It'll do it as many times as we
put in this variable over here.
We're gonna set it up so
we get an accurate number.
We're going to do it a thousand
times for each of those scenarios,
and see what fraction in each scenario,
which fraction do we end up winning?
Voiceover: So, a sample
of a Salman Khan video.
If you can deconstruct yourself a little
bit, other than getting people's attention
by using LeBron James,
what's the technique in there
that makes it more
user-friendly than other things?
Voiceover: When I started
these, it was for my cousins,
and I didn't really
think about it too much.
I just said, "Well, it's for my cousin.
"I'll just do these somewhat
informally, very conversationally."
I didn't show my face, because
I didn't feel like I needed to.
I was already tutoring my cousins,
and they just heard my voice
and we could see what we were writing.
Later, we've gotten a lot
of feedback from people,
and that's why we've tried not
to diverge too much from that,
that they really liked this form factor.
They didn't feel like there was
someone distant at a chalkboard saying,
"Oh, the next step is XYZ"
It felt like we were at
the kitchen table together.
They felt like I was an
older brother or a cousin,
explaining these types of ideas.
We tried to retain that,
that conversationality,
the humanity in it, the
connection with the learner.
Voiceover: Listeners,
if you want to call in,
we can take a few phone
calls for Salman Khan.
I see some people are already calling in,
who want to do testimonials, that
they've been using the system.
So, 212-433-WNYC, if you
want to talk to Salman Khan.
His new book is called, "The One World
School House, Education Reimagined."
212-433-9692, and Miguel in
Queens, you're on the air.
Hi, Miguel.
Voiceover: Hi, how are you,
Ryan, and hello, Mr. Khan.
I just want to let you
know that I understand
why the video, the
first video, went viral.
I'm going to college at night, and I feel
that the professors just want
to go through the whole program,
so they actually explained all.
They just go through the class very fast.
If I don't understand something,
and I want them to explain it again,
they will explain one time, but
then they just [unintelligible] -
Voiceover: So you went to some Salman Khan
videos that dealt with the same material?
Voiceover: Yes, I went on
Youtube and looked for videos
so I could understand my calculus
classes, Calculus I and 2.
Because I was able to see it
once, and again and again,
I was able to understand and
actually pass the classes.
Voiceover: That's great, Miguel,
and I'm sure that warms your heart.
Voiceover: Stories like Miguel's,
for myself and the rest of our team,
that's what keeps us going.
Voiceover: Are you like the
SparkNotes of YouTube, in a way?
If people are not getting it on their
own, they can go get a quick tutorial?
Voiceover: Yeah, but there's
one thing about that comparison
that I think isn't completely there,
which would be whenever people
think about ten-minute videos,
they think, "Oh, maybe
this is the SparkNotes
"or the Cliff Notes of mathematics."
What I always point out
is that we can do as many
of these 10-minute videos as we want,
so we're not limited by 50 minutes
or 90 minutes in a lecture hall.
What we get a lot of feedback from
students on is that we go into depth.
We have a lot of examples.
We go into the proofs, the conceptual
"how does it apply to the real world?"
Voiceover: When you try to use
this, not just in this way,
but as a model for reforming education,
part of your concept is
called the flipped classroom.
Explain.
Voiceover: It's not my concept, actually.
Very few of the concepts in
the book are new concepts.
They're re-invigorated concepts.
This is in the early days when
it's mainly the videos out there.
I had teachers coming to me, emailing me,
Saying, "Hey, look.
"You've already given an
interesting lecture about
probability or about calculus.
"Why should I use my scarce class time
to do this one-pace kind of lecture,
"and the students are
sitting there passively?
"Instead, they can watch your stuff
at their own time and their own pace,
and then we can use class time
for something more interactive."
Once again, the flip idea existed
before us, but what I did is,
what used to be homework is now
class work, problem solving,
and now you have your peers
and the teacher to help you.
What used to be class time, which
is lectures, you get on demand.
You can remediate.
We think you can go even further.
In the book, I go into a lot of depth,
how you can go much beyond,
even doing the flip.
Voiceover: Such as?
Voiceover: Even the flip assumes
kind of a Prussian model,
that we're all going to be learning
at the same pace, the same
thing, at the same time.
As soon as you remove
the one-pace-fits-all
lecture from the classroom,
you say, "Well, maybe we could
have two teachers in the classroom
teaching twice as many students.
"Maybe we could have every student
learning at their own pace,
"breaking away from this
assembly-line model.
"Maybe we could have students
start to tutor each other.
"Maybe this opens up time for creativity,
so they can do more open-ended projects."
Voiceover: Keith in
Washington Heights calling
with, I think, a little bit of
skepticism about the flip classroom.
Yes, Keith?
Voiceover: Good morning, gentlemen.
I first heard about this
Khan Academy on "60 Minutes,"
and they showed it in a classroom, where
the kids were learning from Khan Academy,
and then the teacher would
circulate around the room
for anybody that needed additional help.
Don't get me wrong.
I think the idea is great, and I've
watched a number of your videos there.
I don't think you can
replace the teacher because,
even when you're teaching your cousin,
if you're on the phone with her
and talking to her directly,
and having interaction back and forth,
when she says, "I got that point.
"Move on," or, "I don't have this point.
"Repeat it," somehow it's different.
Let me explain it better.
Let me explain it differently.
When I'm teaching my
students, I have interaction.
I stop at each point.
"Do we get it?
"Do we not get it?
"Who doesn't get it?
"What needs to be further explained?"
There's something lost when
you're just doing it on a video.
It's great stuff, but
it's not the same thing
as having a teacher explaining
it directly, and having an
interaction with the kids.
Voiceover: Keith, thank you.
Salman.
Voiceover: I a hundred
percent agree with Keith.
Actually, that was a
big point of this book,
is whenever people come up with
something virtual, the assumption is,
"Oh, this is going to compete
with the physical" - Amazon.com
versus Barnes and Noble's.
Everything that we emphasize
is, what we are doing is a tool
for students and for teachers.
What it is, it allows class time to
be less based on a passive lecture,
and more of the things that Keith just
talked about, more of the interaction.
When my cousins were able to
do the exercises on their own
and the videos on their own,
when they had time with me, I didn't
have to do any explaining to them,
or I had to just fill in the gaps
that the videos didn't cover.
So, I a hundred percent agree.
I have young children.
I do not want them to
learn only from a computer.
I want that to actually be a very
small fraction of their learning.
Voiceover: You were talking before
about a possible multi-teacher model
in the classroom while
they're using the visuals.
Have you costed out what
it would take financially
to use this as a
nationally-scaleable model?
Maybe you saw President Obama
in the debate last night,
talking about that teacher
with the 42-student classroom.
We're already strapped, in other words.
Voiceover: Yeah, we're already
strapped and, obviously,
even an extra penny is
going to cost something.
Technology is getting cheaper every year.
I don't think you even need
one computer per child.
You could have one computer,
because they're not going
to be spending all day on the computer.
A computer's now two or
three hundred dollars.
A new laptop or tablet device
can last four or five years,
and be shared by four or five students.
Really, it starts becoming on the order
of ten, twenty dollars a student a year.
I think it becomes
cost-competitive with textbooks,
which I really think is where this
could be more of a substitute,
not for the teacher, but for the textbook.
Voiceover: Now, you've
got people's attention,
because everybody wants to
replace those expensive textbooks,
that also get updated every few years
and you have to keep buying them.
Dan in Brooklyn, we have time
for one more testimonial,
and it'll come from Dan.
Hi, Dan.
Voiceover: Hi, I just want
to say as a neurobiologist
that I really want to thank you for
saving the brains of so many children.
Really, what people don't realize is
that the brain proliferates
with connections and songs
from the age one onward
to about 12, 13 years old.
Then, it crashes and a lot of brain
cells and brain connections are lost -
about 30% of them.
What you're doing is making available
to children conceptual operations
that will keep those
connections vibrant and alive.
That's the European way of teaching
so that, right after high school,
they go right to professional school -
no wasting four years of college that make
up for 12 lost years of public education.
Voiceover: Is that part of your goal,
right on to professional
school from high school?
Voiceover: That's not the goal.
It's not NOT the goal either.
The goal is actually to introduce
more variety into the system.
In the book, I go into some detail -
this 12 years of primary and secondary,
and you learn physics your senior year.
This was determined in 1892 by ten men,
mainly university presidents,
the Committee of Ten.
I think it's time that we re-think
this 200-year-old Prussian model.
It's time we re-think this 120-year-old
Committee of Ten proposition.
It doesn't have to be exactly
what the caller is saying,
but it doesn't have to be
exactly what we're saying now.
It can be more flexible.
Voiceover: Salman Khan -
he's an inspiration to many.
His new book is called, "The One World
School House, Education Reimagined."
By the way, you can access
all the Khan Academy materials
online at Khan Academy dot org.
Great to speak with you.
Thank you for coming in.
Voiceover: Thanks for having me.
Voiceover: Right, we're at WNYC.